starting off this hour is going to be
Houston Texas Roisin I as weather Saira
Sheena how are you I've been better day
oh what's going on I hate to use this
term but I'm drowning I've been reading
your books in your program for the last
couple months you know what I could get
at the library and watching your videos
online but everything's kind of come to
a head and I'm losing myself so a bit a
lot and I'm not sure what to do I'm
considering bankruptcy at this point not
sure if I'm supposed to go back to
school I just honestly don't know what
to do right now how old are you I'm 28
and how much do you make a year at best
I make around 19,000 what do you do um
right now I'm a substitute teacher okay
you have a teaching certificate no I owe
a debt that's actually preventing me
from getting a certificate so I
understand Oh a college in order to do
the teaching program in Texas you have
to have all your transcripts but because
our school they won't release it and
they won't let me go with the
transcripts I have digestion and how
much do you owe them I owe them around
1,300 1,300 dollars yes okay and how
quickly would you land a job were you to
get your transcript do you think I'm
pretty quickly I spend something I know
this is going to sound so silly but I've
been something for about four years
the thing is the money's not constant
I'm not working doing the funds I don't
work doing major holidays so do you live
on your own yes
you're barely making it aren't you kiddo
I'm barely making it so much student
hold it no much other loan debt do you
have not counting us thirteen hundred Oh
60 mm mm yeah it's overwhelming making
19 and what other kind of debt have you
got I have considered it I've taken out
I know through stupid decisions are
taken out on payday loans I have a card
note that got repossessed last year they
want 12,000 on it and I have a little
car loan because I couldn't take cash
and so I'm paying that - how much do you
owe on that hour no one right now on
five grand
how much is your payment I'm 200 a night
okay all right well let's walk through
this for a second okay if you were to
file bankruptcy a chapter 7 bankruptcy
is the type of bankruptcy that cleans
off all your debts okay student loan
debt is not bankrupt a bull so a
bankruptcy would not clean off the
sixty-two thousand it might clean off
the 1301 I don't know that sounds like
that's a private debt and that one might
be cleaned it would clean off your old
repossession it would clean off the
payday loans it would not clean up the
five thousand dollar debt on the car
unless you turn the car in you don't get
to turn you don't get to get rid of the
debt and keep the car you follow me yes
sir
so you either keep the debt and keep the
car or you turn the car in and can get
rid of that debt okay if you want my
opinion I don't think you have a debt
problem as much as you have a huge
income problem I definitely agree with
that if we if we could increase your
income ten fifteen thousand dollars a
year you still wouldn't be making a ton
of money but it would change your life
right now because let me kind of give
you this number okay
thirteen hundred changes your income
because you get the transcripts back
five thousand gets rid of the car dad
how much is only stupid payday loans why
I only took out 800 but as you know the
interest rate how much is how much you
owe on the stupid payday loans umm 1,700
now okay so let's do this math $8,000
1,700 there 1,300 at the college 5,000
on your car changes your whole life yes
sir that makes sense yes 8,000 bucks and
then you've got a student loan that
you're gonna have to work your way
through but you've got to work your way
through that anyway you're not getting
away from that one and you've got an old
repo of 12,000 dollars that you probably
could settle for a couple grand so 10
grand cleans up your entire life and
makes it awesome not counting the fact
you got to fight through 62 thousand
dollars where the student loans so you
know that tells me that you really don't
have a bankruptcy problem you've really
got a I mean a debt problem you got an
income problem so you owe much is your
rent 600 okay
I'm not okay and so here's what I want
you to have you ever waited tables or
delivered pizzas
I wasn't waitress when I was a teen
mm-hmm okay and you're 26 you said 28 28
okay alright what I would tell you to do
if I woke up in your shoes knowing what
I know and see I don't have all the
emotions of being overwhelmed and scared
I'm just looking at the math so I've got
an advantage right now okay
you've got the emotions of being
overwhelmed and scared I'm just looking
at the math and that gives me an
advantage I'm outside the forest so I
can see all the trees you're following
me yes I get that you're overwhelmed and
scared but I can tell you how to fix it
I mean if I were you I'd start working
about 80 hours a week 90 hours a week
I'd be delivering pizzas and waiting
tables and whatever else you can come up
with to make money tutoring I'd be
tutoring model but off
and a lady was on her last hour making
30 bucks an hour and Charlotte tutoring
as a teacher and that's how she got out
of debt 30 bucks an hour would change
your life you know pick up three or four
kids pick up three or four places you
can wait tables and pick up pick up a
jobs doing whatever I don't know what
you can do this legal and moral but I
want you to go make an extra two or
three thousand dollars a month but you
have no life you can't breathe you're so
tired your nostrils hurt you follow me
you know what to worry about though you
won't die from hard work right before
you die you'll pass out you'll be okay
you follow me yes you need to work your
butt off your fingers to the bone and go
make you ten thousand dollars in the
next four months Christmas I want you
debt-free except the student loans and
the car repo you get your transcripts
back you get the payday lenders out of
your life don't you ever go in one of
those places again they're killing you
and get your car paid off and then
you're gonna have a life you feel it
okay you can do this I'll walk with you
you call me back while you're working on
it and you and I'll do this together and
you hold on I'm gonna put you through
Financial Peace University to get a
community in your life where you can
walk through this and get it done you
got this kid you can do it
but it's gonna you just need a little
bit of money and a way to get that's
work like a crazy person
hold on Kelly I'll pick up hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]